le quiero empezar preguntando por una
breve análisis de A qué responde La
retirada rusa de gerson
bueno no sabemos lo que tiene Putin en
la cabeza Pero hay tres posibilidades
que están manejando en todos los
análisis de inteligencia Y seguridad uno
que abandonan como una especie de Berlín
de los años 40 para ser la ciudad a
partir de la cual se pueda negociar con
Ucrania un fin de la guerra bajo la
presión de Estados Unidos China India
entre otros una segunda variante sería
que se ha refugiado en más en el
profundo bombas Putin porque son tampoco
lo necesitaba desde el punto de vista
geoestratégico y la tercera que pretenda
dar una señal hacia Ucrania que le haga
bajar sus exigencias a la hora de una
negociación eso es lo que se está
barajando otra cosa es lo que realmente
después ocurra la semana pasada vaiden
ya estableció una línea de comunicación
constante con Putin hace unos 4 o 5 días
china e India hablaron con Putin
diciendo que eso tenía que acabar y por
otra parte la Unión Europea hacen está
diciendo también que tiene que de alguna
manera negociar con con Rusia pues esto
que esto después puedo convertirse en
una guerra muy muy larga
usted habla de este escenario en que
gerson podría ser un elemento de
negociación en qué sentido
Pues que se convirtiera algo parecido a
una frontera idílica en el que como
Corea del Norte Corea del Sur fuera una
ciudad en la que a partir de ahí se
pudiera negociar porque ambas partes
ceden algo Putin células estratégica muy
importante y al mismo tiempo recupera el
valor de su posición geoestratégica con
con jerson pero había que esperar un
poco la negociaciones nos olvidamos
siempre de que los eslavos negocios de
una manera diferente al resto del mundo
o el resto de los occidentes Si queremos
hablar ahora sí son muy dados a la
negociación pero continúan la batalla
continua la guerra son muy a los modelos
clásicos de trolls entonces para ellos
combatir y negociar no es incompatible
mientras que para nosotros parece
difícil y respecto al segundo de los
escenarios que ustedes estaba comentando
parece que Rusia está construyendo una
línea defensiva en la orilla Oriental
del Río niéper qué sentido estratégico
tendría este río precisamente
precisamente este río el río níper la
parte oriental del río níper es la zona
más prorrosa o era la zona más produsa o
rusofila de toda Ucrania y es una
frontera natural que siempre ha
establecido ha establecido como los
límites a partidos cuales Putin
establecería una seguridad nacional
geoestratégica por tanto La retirada
hasta el río nieper o del río níper
dividiendo a esas zonas de Ucrania
significaría también un punto de
inflexión en el que como hemos dicho
antes se pareciera salvando La distancia
es por supuesto a una Corea del Norte
Corea del Sur para una posible futura
negociación la frontera natural del río
neper siempre desde el punto de vista
estratégico desde el principio de la
guerra se estableció como la frontera
natural de lo que podría ser para Putin
la seguridad que él llama nacional y
para Ucrania toda la parte de control
incluso de salida al mar de lo que
significaría para ellos en la posición
estratégica recuperada y el peso
importante que tienes que son el punto
de vista geopolítico Industrial a pesar
de que Putin ha destruido la
infraestructura críticas de esa ciudad